so with injustice 2 coming out in the
really in the next few days or so to be
honest i think we're probably around
three or four days away which is really
really exciting
what i want to do here is is be a little
bit dangerous i want to go ahead and be
a little risky here and what i want to
do is i want to cover the origin of a
lot of the new characters who are going
to be an injustice but here's the reason
why she were going to be a little bit
dangerous with injustice 1 we didn't
really get the origin story of
characters per se i mean we had things
like nightwing which just turned out to
be damian wayne but we didn't know until
we read the injustice comic how it was
that we got from damien wayne being
robin to becoming nightwing uh that was
one of the great little expositions that
we got but even then we really didn't
get the origin story for a lot of those
characters now a lot of that was because
of the fact that injustice largely
centered on the justice league and it
was really superman just falling down
and becoming an evil guy and so for the
most part because of the legacy of the
characters involved you know green
lantern hal jordan um you know wonder
woman superman batman and so on those
origin stories are for the most part
timeless and most everybody knows what
they are and so it wasn't really
necessary for dc to give us those
origins but if injustice 2 if that comic
follows the trend of injustice 1 then
darkseid will just suddenly be there you
know brainiac will just be there we may
or may not get those origin stories and
so what i wanted to do was grab this
origin from dc comics and throw it in
and so it may be that when the game
comes out this changes it may be this is
the origin they go with they may never
even confirm this is the origin but at
the very least it'll give you a general
idea of what to expect and what the
motivations are behind the character of
brainiac so the most recent origin for
his character came out of a one shot of
i think it was superman 23.2 as part of
the new 52. now keep in mind when dc
rebooted in 2011 the idea was to
basically just kind of restart
everything from scratch the only
exceptions being green lantern hal
jordan and batman but with regards to
the superman mythos new origin stories
were given for a lot of characters dark
side brainiac so on and so forth and so
because of that what this does is it
basically shows us what brainiac is all
about now initially this picks up in
three locations uh the first is planet
jazur i think is how you pronounce it
the second is a planet brya and the
third is planet noma and these are all
three different individuals who have
some similarity and physical appearance
to brainiac himself and the reason why
is because on the planet noma a person
that's basically being being taken is a
person named victoria viceroy now the
reason why victoria viceroy is has been
taken here will be explained by the time
we get uh by the time we get to the end
of the story but what ends up happening
is that this sort of field commander i
guess or this aspect of brainiac
basically begins telling her everything
that's going on why it is that they're
here and what it does is it basically
winds back to the early days of a guy by
the name of real docs now real docs was
basically displayed here as a genius as
a scientist of sorts but something that
i want you to notice is that there are a
lot of similarities between what goes on
with regards to this story and what goes
on with the origin of superman they're
not identical and they're not designed
to be but there are a lot of
similarities now initially all we really
have is real docs just kind of
experimenting on someone and we assume
that it's just a random individual some
person he's taken somewhere along the
lines but when his wife enters the room
we end up finding out that real docs is
experimenting on his son now we don't
really know exactly what his motivations
are at the moment all we know is that
he's basically going through and
performing some kind of experiment on
him now the similarities between
brainiac and superman only come in so
far that it's a mother it's a it's a
father and it's a son i mean you know
we'll get into a few more of the
similarities later on but that's one of
the things that i wanted to sort of
point out is because with superman
having been the template or the standard
behind all modern day superheroes and
even some super villains his origin
story is the definitive origin story in
terms of just timeless stories so
because of that a lot of the origins
that came later on down the line were in
some form or fashion modeled after him
that is to say you know a person an
individual or a being that loses those
around him people that have to make
sacrifices different things like that
but of course the response of real dox's
wife is one of absolute disgust similar
because of the fact that he's
experimenting on their child now this is
when we start to get in a few more
similarities in terms of real docs
basically speaking to the committee of
the planet that they're on you know yad
yad kolu i think is how you pronounce it
but what he basically says is that
through his own studies through his own
research he's basically discovered
something called the fifth dimension now
we as readers of dc comics know the
fifth dimension is the home of like mr
mixopetalic and batmite individuals who
have you know technology that's so
extreme that it might as well be magic
and so because of that the abilities of
individuals inside the fifth dimension
allow them to effectively warp reality
in a three-dimensional space and so what
this means is that with these various
wars and conflicts taking place inside
the fifth dimension some individuals or
some groups of one of which is referred
to as the multitude has basically
engineered its escape now the way the
multitude is depicted here in this story
is that they are in fact what amounts to
a force of nature i mean they're like
well really they're kind of described as
locus and in a lot of ways they are uh
but where locusts will show up and
they'll eat you know plant life and
different things like that crops and so
on and so forth the multitude will just
raise worlds and then destroy them and
so they basically wipe out everything
that they come across and so what what
was going on here with regards to real
docs experimenting on his son as he was
basically saying hey look you know this
group is coming towards us this group is
coming to our planet the reason why i
was experimenting on my son was to
basically find a way to uh to
effectively enhance our people to move
us in a direction so that when this
group arrives here we can find a way to
fight them off now again this is very
you know end of times apocalyptian very
similar to the superman mythos which is
to say jorel basically discovering the
impending destruction of krypton trying
to find a way to save it the council
that was ruling over krypton at the time
refused to hear him out and it resulted
in the planet's destruction with
superman being sent away as its sole
survivor and so because of this the
origin story of brainiac is very similar
in the sense that this committee refuses
to hear him out they consider him to be
crazy because of that he's basically
exiled and he is sent away now at this
point this is when dc begins to get into
just how intense and how intelligent
brainiac is what we end up finding out
here is that real docs was basically the
guy who engineered the computer systems
of his home planet and so while he was
basically sent away because he had
engineered the computer system designed
to keep him captive the committee that
had him arrested basically threw him in
a cell and then gave him the key and so
because of this virile docs basically
uses his own abilities that is to say
basically the things that he had
programmed into the software to allow
him to seize control at any point in
time and basically takes control of this
program and then reinstitutes his own
computer program which is basically just
his own interface the ability for him to
talk to the computer so on and so forth
but what ends up happening is he begins
the process of manipulating his own
physical structure now in terms of the
steps he takes to do this dc does not
really give us an in-depth explanation
in a lot of ways brainiac is symbolic
because of how he looks but more so than
that it's the things that he does that
make him so dangerous the fact that he's
so intelligent the fact that he's so
cold the fact that he's so calculating
that's what makes him so interesting
he's like a far more extreme version of
lex luthor and so because of this
brainiac basically returns back to his
world and says hey look i'm here to save
you guys i'm here to save all of you
because this world is going to be
destroyed now notice that where he had
previously pleaded to the committee who
was there now he's making demands and it
raises some pretty interesting points
here because it's like if he warned them
that their destruction was imminent and
they refused to listen then it begs the
question well what road would you take
would you simply leave them to their
fate would you say hey look i tried to
warn you you didn't want to listen now
you have to deal with the consequences
welcome to the world of what happens
when you fail to to heed advice that's
going to benefit you or he simply just
does what he's doing now and whisks some
of them away but what this does is it
sets him down the path of the most
notable act that brainiac consistently
commits one of the things that brainiac
is most known for is the fact that he
basically captures and bottles cities
that's his thing now the fact that he
does that is brought him to earth on a
multitude of occasions in an attempt to
basically whisk things away and that was
the basis behind the whole convergence
event but the idea here is that the
first city that he wrote i guess the
first place that he basically takes is
the city in which his wife and his son
exists now this is him not doing it
because he's altruistic this is him just
doing it as a matter of practicality and
that's what he ends up doing for he just
travels from one location to the next
basically showing up on planets that are
next on the list of planets that will be
destroyed by the multitude stealing one
of their cities and then taking them
away now because of this of course the
home planet of real docks is basically
obliterated in its entirety and it's
kind of ironic because it's only in the
moment of complete and total destruction
that the people who banished him
realized he was right it's a bit of
irony of sorts but even then he
basically goes back about creating
multiple aspects of himself and that's
really what's established here that
there is the prime brainiac and then
there's the other versions that people
most commonly see and it was really the
most intelligent way of doing things and
the reason why is because if he were to
go on a quest to basically preserve some
form of all the different worlds that
will eventually be destroyed by the
multitude then it would take too long he
would basically fall behind because a
multitude moves so incredibly fast but
by making different aspects of himself
he's able to basically preserve one
portion of these different worlds now
here's the kicker to this is that with
brainiac capturing these different you
know happening different cities or
capturing a city on a world the idea
here is he's basically just saying i'm
going to preserve a part of this world
because their destruction is nigh
they're they're you know the end is
imminent and so because of this
eventually he comes across krypton now
the funny thing about this is that
krypton at this point in time is not on
the verge of complete and total
destruction and in fact jorel is still
basically studying the planet and will
eventually come to the realization that
it's going to be obliterated in its
entirety but during this particular
point in time when brainiac first visits
brainiac actually goes there and steals
the city of kandor and so that's where
that's where the the you know the really
famous name the bottled city of candor
that you've probably heard of before
that's where that comes from brainiac
basically takes that as one of the
cities because in his mind krypton is
going to be yet another world that's
destroyed by the multitude the kicker is
that jurell actually finds a way to fend
off against the multitude now as far as
i'm aware we're not given the story on
how that happens um at least if we have
i haven't been able to find it but the
fact that joerl was able to help fight
off the multitude and preserve krypton
led brainiac to return back to uh back
to krypton itself in order to find out
what it was that jorel did so that
brainiac could basically copy whatever
it was you know whatever that act was
duplicate it and then use that to
effectively fight off and destroy the
multitude within the dc universe the
problem is that by the time brainiac got
back krypton had been destroyed and
superman was on his way to earth and so
because of this what it does is it
circles back around to this particular
uh i guess this this whole thing with
victoria viceroy and what happens is the
prime brainiac shows up when she begins
making declarations of his you know this
aspect of himself where she says look
you know show me you know tell me what
it is that he's doing what's he actually
after and what brainiac says is that it
is true he's not being altruistic he's
not preserving these different cities
because it's the right thing to do he's
preserving these cities because for him
if he cannot keep the planet if he can't
save the planet then he's going to
destroy before the multitude can not
only that when he gets to the planet
when he gets to a world that's going to
be destroyed by the multitude if he
cannot find anyone who can basically
duplicate what it was jorel did and
being successful in destroying the
multitude then brainiac will destroy
that planet first and so that's one of
the one of the crazy things he's on a
very dark path you know it's does this
planet have the ability to destroy the
multitude if they don't steal a city
blow up the planet and that's really
where he's at right now that's pretty
much all he does is travel the space
ways doing exactly that so what ends up
happening here is that this ultimately
results in the fact that brainiac
realizes victoria viceroy does not have
the ability to preserve you know the
planet noma and fight off the multitude
so of course he basically leads her to
her fate and annihilates the planet but
what this does is this segues into the
new 52 superman going forward into a new
story arc so again we can kind of wrap
it up here um this is really where like
the origin of brainiac really begins to
come to a close
okay so a lot of you guys really seem to
enjoy these origins for injustice 2 but
atrocitus is going to be a little bit
different here and the reason why is
because this video really this origin as
we see it here is very much a part of
jeff john's green lantern mythos and so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to tag
this in both the jeff john's green
lantern playlist and the injustice 2
playlist so if you happen to come across
this in the green lantern uh videos and
you'll understand why it's here but why
i'm talking about injustice so uh with
regards to atrocities and really a lot
of the characters something i want to
reiterate from when we first you know
started talking about brainiac was that
not every character in injustice is the
new 52 counterpart but a lot of them are
in the sense of their origins are
similar but there are a few changes here
and there the issue is that in injustice
we never really got origins for those
characters they were simply just there
and again a lot of that was because of
the fact that it was the justice league
and so you know we could just kind of
take the st take the characters with a
grain of salt assume their origins were
almost identical and pretty much go
forward plus the story wasn't really
about their origin so much as it was
about them just fighting each other and
you know becoming evil and so on and so
forth but the fact remains here
atrocitus is a new introduction to the
injustice mythos and he is probably one
of my favorite characters i love the red
lantern for red's probably my favorite
just because of the fact they're just
evil man
like they're just just evil like
they're just bad people and uh and it's
kind of cool to see the whole thing
unfold but the good thing about this is
that with this origin it's just as much
a part of the green lantern mythos as it
is about atrocities himself so what this
does is this picks up on the planet
reu'd or react i'm not sure exactly how
you pronounce it i'm going to say ryu
just because i think it sounds better
sounds like ryu but um this basically
picks up with the man hunters now for
those of you guys who are new to the
green lantern mythos and again we cover
green lantern stuff every sunday or
right now we're doing infinite crisis
which goes into green lanterns and we're
doing that every sunday um the man
hunters were basically the guardians of
the universe first attempt to create a
police force within the universe in the
sense that once they basically disbanded
emotion from themselves uh they created
the manhunters as androids to carry out
and keep order across the cosmos now of
course on planet reut this is very much
a major role for the character of uh of
atros or i guess uh atrocious however we
want to pronounce it who essentially has
a wife and kids and again for him it's
really just life as usual he doesn't
really have a whole lot of pause for
concern his daughter takes notice of the
fact that the man hunters seem to be a
little more sinister than they were
before but coming from you know an adult
perspective this really seems to be a
byproduct of a child's imagination the
reason why is because atos basically
says look these are androids they don't
have emotion they have programming they
do what their programming entails which
is actually kind of cool and really true
for example if you guys ever read a book
called how the mind works by stephen
pinker he basically runs over why it is
that skynet couldn't happen but the idea
here is that there's actually truth to
the words of aetrus's daughter in the
sense that the manhunters are actually
going awry now the man hunters are still
robots the manhunters do still have
programming but it's more of a glitch
than anything else it's not like the
manhunters became sentient organisms
it's something that the manhunters carry
out a task assigned to them by somebody
else if that programming is screwed up
they will become villains now what they
do by virtue of their programming being
screwed up which was actually done by a
guy named krona we end up finding that
out later on down the line the man
hunters begin going on a campaign
killing off everybody on this planet
every single person and the reason why
is because to the man hunters modified
programming organisms that have free
will will use that free will to engage
and contradictory actions for example
warfare you know people who value life
in turn wage war against one another
which results in a loss of life and so
because of that these various beings
much like normal humans are
contradictory you know how can you say
that we want to continue living when
they're moving ever closer to their own
extinction through conventional and
advanced forms of war and so because of
this the manhunters basically
obliterated all of them now it wasn't
just ryu this happened all across the
cosmos but the issue is that within the
sector 666 which is really more of like
a demon realm so to be kind of like the
a dark magic section of the universe uh
the result is that both the wife and the
daughter of atros are completely
destroyed now at this point we start
picking up with the introduction of
these sort of demon entities and what
these beings do or at least what these
individuals do is they kind of delve in
really what passes for black magic in
the realm of uh dc comics as far as like
space-faring races and their own brand
of powers and so on and so forth go but
what they do is they approach atros
calling themselves really like the four
demons now these individuals were looked
down upon and banished by the guardians
but with the rampage taking place across
sector 666 what it does is it allows
them to rise to prominence once more now
with regards to aetros himself he's
filled with absolute rage and that's why
this is so cool is because it's a person
that lost their family and something
that's really interesting about this is
that i would surmise truth be told i
would surmise that in justice 1 it would
have made more sense for superman to
become a red lantern as opposed to a
yellow lantern but at the time it was
just kind of building on the mythos as
it existed and really even then the red
lanterns were still such a relatively
new concept it made more sense to use
the green lanterns and the sinestro
corps instead of the red lantern corps
just because the cenatroport was so
popular back then so even if only for
the sake of just good storytelling and
drawing people in the senestral core was
used but the implication here or the
similarities between atros and superman
and injustice are astounding in the
sense that remember in the injustice
story superman lost his mind he went
crazy he started you know going on a
rampage and sent the world into a state
of complete and total totalitarian rule
because of the fact that the joker
tricked him into killing his wife an
unborn child tricked him into killing
lois lane with atros is a little
different just because of the fact it is
an external force that resulted in the
annihilation of his family but the end
result is still the same they've lost
the people that they care about how they
respond to it is entirely different so
that's that's one of the cool things
here is because one of the things you'll
find in comics is there's a lot of
similarities between characters as they
exist uh you know with regards to their
origin stories and so on and so forth
but the fact remains here that these uh
these demons approach atrios and say
look you're a man filled with rage
you've literally gone on a rampage and
killed so many man hunters we want to
give you the power to organize us and so
this is when when they really look to
him not necessarily as a leader but as a
kind of rallying point and i know it
seems like semantics but it's actually
not a leader role was a person who
basically says here are the things that
we're going to do here the goals are
going to carry out with regards to these
four demons their minds aren't cohesive
their minds don't function in a true
capacity in the sense that they
basically wonder around they don't have
focus what they're hoping is that
through his rage atrocity the one this
able to to basically organize them to
keep their minds together and say we
have to keep our eyes on the prize so
again it's really more of like a
rallying point as opposed to you know an
actual traditional leader of sorts now
what this does is it allows you know
ahrefs and this group being
re-identified as the five inversions it
allows them to spend several millennia
traveling around the universe waging war
against all the man hunters and even the
guardians themselves and but that's
really the crux of the hatred of
atrocitus is the fact that for him it's
really the guardians who set this thing
in motion the guardians created the
manhunters the guardians allowed the
manhunters to continue existing even
after the massacre of sector 666 the
guardians are the ones behind all this
and so the goal of atrocitus is to
annihilate the manhunters in their
entirety and annihilate you know the
guardians and of themselves now the path
to atrocitus becoming the red lantern
picks up when he basically begins
speaking or at least tries to speak
again with one of the members of the
inversions a woman named uh named roy um
or or roxoom i'm not really sure how you
pronounce it i'm not very good in french
i actually failed that class in college
so i have no idea uh exactly how you
pronounce that but we're going to call
it rocks we're going to call it rock
soon i've seen that's pretty much the
way to say it but what we find out is
that between the time when they first
began their crusade to annihilate these
man hunters up until the present day
that atrocities had constantly
approached roxum for the purpose of
learning blood magic in the sense that
it would allow him to see the future now
the issue here is that roxanne says look
if you do this it will drive you insane
send your entire life into a tailspin
the future is something that you should
not dabble in that you should not mess
with now the irony about this is that uh
ultimately atrocitus basically tricks
her atrocities says you know well the
the whole reason why i'm here in the
first place the whole reason why i want
to learn the whole reason why we're so
close is because i love you so it's
really just him kind of spewing what he
needs to say in order to get the result
that he wants now something else is
interesting here is again he's really
following the trend of superman and
injustice just tumbling further down the
rabbit hole to the point that he loses
all semblance of himself now the
difference here is that superman's
morality was so incorruptible before he
lost his mind and allowed himself to be
corrupted that even when he became a bad
guy he rep he became a bad guy only in
so far that he felt like he was doing
the right thing he felt like he was
saving the world so there was still a
measure of morality there but he was
basically kind of pushing that nagging
voice in the back of his head away and
saying i'm doing the right thing with
atrocitus he just wants to wipe out the
guardians it's a far more basic far more
visceral emotion it's an emotion of rage
but it's one that guides his every
waking thought and every sleeping dream
and so because of this what he ends up
doing is he basically you know has a
getting together of sorts let your
imagination run wild on that with
regards to rock soon and she basically
teaches him blood magic and what she
says is that in order to see the future
you have to basically use the blood of
others feed on your own rage and then
see what the future has to offer and so
of course stealing or i guess kidnapping
one of the guardians he does exactly
that and what he sees is the death of
the other four inversions with himself
standing solo so again it's really him
seeing these events unfold and what it
does is it begs the question is this
future guaranteed and what i mean by
that is one of the funny things that
people deal with when it comes to the
idea of like seeing the future in comics
is is that future guaranteed if it is
then no matter what you do it will
always lead to that future so for
example if you were sitting at a fork in
the road and you were considering going
right but you wanted to look at the
future and see what direction you were
going to go in and you end up seeing in
the future that you end up going left
well then the question is did you
influence your own choice are you the
reason why you ended up going left in
the future as opposed to going right
because you saw what the future had to
offer in the future change your position
even then if that's the case is every
decision you make ever you know going to
guarantee the future that you saw for
yourself so again it's really kind of
weird here but the fact remains that uh
over the course of their campaigns
eventually they're captured by the
guardians of the universe and they're
basically held prisoner on the planet
ismael now once they're held captive
here atrocitus manages to free himself
and then kills the other four inversions
just like he saw in his own future and
so because of that in the midst of his
rage and in the midst of his of his
wrath what he does is he taps into the
rage emotion from the emotional spectrum
and what it does is it basically spits
out a lantern to him and allows him to
basically form his own central power
battery and so what is up happening here
is atrocitus uses the emotion of rage to
power himself and the result is that he
fires up a second blood prophecy and
looks into the future only to see that
he's basically going to form his own red
lantern core so again the origin of
trousers is really pretty
straightforward here especially just a
guy whose family was destroyed when the
man hunters you know formed by the
guardians of the universe went awry and
the result was that he uh essentially
just started waging a war against him
fell to the dark side tapped in right i
don't know i fell into the dark side he
became darth vader fell to the dark side
learned to tap into the rage aspect of
the emotional spectrum and that really
set him on his honest collision course
to forming the red lantern core but
again just a pretty straightforward
origin pretty quick pretty simple
nothing too major here
so a lot of you guys really really seem
to enjoy the whole idea of injustice
origins running over the origin story of
some of the newer characters and even
some of the established characters and
injustice granted we're only a couple in
we're only with brainiac and atrocitus
but um in truth i was really just trying
to find a way to kind of keep injustice
relevant on my channel while we were
waiting for you know the actual comic to
start and the first story arc to finish
and so on and so forth so again uh what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna cover
the origin of reverse flash eobard
thawne just because of the fact that at
the time that i'm recording this video i
feel like it's going to be eobard
thought it might not be and if it's not
we'll do the origin story of the person
who's actually you know actually is the
reverse flash but i have a hard time
believing it wouldn't be eobard thon
just because of the fact that he's the
most iconic person to hold the mantle of
reverse flash slash professor zoom so
because of this there's a little bit of
context that i want to throw in here and
what this does is it comes out of a
story called the return of barry allen
keep in mind barry allen basically died
during crisis on infinite earths but dc
had set the stage for barry allen
returning at some point along the line
because he would just kind of appear
from from the speed force speak to you
know wally west or somebody sometimes as
a disembodied voice sometimes as an
illusion or a physical being but then he
would just go right back into the speed
force again and that would basically be
the end of him um all indications from
dc was that wally west is now the flash
and it will stay that way until some
future point in time so with the story
the return of barry allen this is one of
those that basically turned everybody's
head and the reason why is because of
the fact that people still liked the
idea of barry allen a lot of people who
were picking up with the flash wally
west were curious about barry allen but
in their mind wally west was the only
flash they wanted and so what happened
over the course of the story is that it
was revealed this is not actually barry
allen this is eobard thon now uh thawne
had appeared before a crisis on infinite
earth and he had his own stories and
different things like that but
post-crisis keep in mind dc was
revitalizing its landscape and so what
they did is they revitalized the origin
of eobard thon now he did get a new
origin in the new 52 but this particular
story has been done in so many ways it's
been done in the flash tv show it's been
done in animated movies and so because
of that i feel like or maybe it's been
hinted at in animated movies but i feel
like this origin is so iconic for eobard
thon it would really be the only
reasonable one to use so because of this
what this does is it basically led to a
cat and mouse game between wally west
and eobard thon as wally was beginning
to pick up the clues and realize that
barry allen was not barry allen that it
was actually eobard's thought and so
with the two of them basically meeting
for this final showdown what is up
happening as eobard begins to go through
what his origin story is and what he
does is he basically tells wally that he
hails from the uh from the the 25th
century and the 25th century as eobard
thon describes it is both a place of
enlightenment but it's also a place
that's not welcoming for individuals who
cherish the idea of superheroes now the
reason behind this is not because
superheroes are looked down on it's
nothing like that it's simply because of
the fact that there's no need for
superheroes anymore that you know the
various agencies that you know help
maintain peace across the globe do so
using technology and so the idea of
batman is no longer necessary superman
has presumably long since left a lot of
the people who are traditional
superheroes as we think of them are no
longer part of the equation because
again there's no need for them but from
the perspective of eobard thawne this is
his torment this is his prison he is one
of a handful of individuals who looked
to the idea of heroes and what they
stood for and believed that heroes were
one of the greatest things to exist and
so because that like a lot of scholars
and so on and so forth eobard thon was
obsessed with heroes specifically he was
obsessed with the flash he was obsessed
with him in such an extreme degree that
his idea was to basically find a way to
meet barry allen one day now what mark
white is doing here with regards to this
little bit of a story is he's
essentially telling us that e of our
thon's obsession with barry allen
borders on the realm of insanity and in
fact he even undergoes you know this
moral essentially surgery basically to
make himself look like barry allen so
that shows you how extreme he was
willing to go he's the ultimate fanboy
more or less but what ended up happening
here is he was he basically took kind of
this historical journal's historical
text of source this journal for the
flash and intended to take it into the
past and then turn around and you know
have barry allen signing the problem
with this was that accessing the past
was a very difficult thing to do it was
almost impossible until he found an
artifact that would allow him to time
travel and so because this his dream had
become reality you know it was like
going to a convention and being able to
meet like every single one of you guys
it's just like this is amazing i mean
it's something that that you hope to do
one day but it's virtually impossible
and so because of that eobard thought
being able to meet uh really his his
idol in a lot of different ways was an
opportunity that he shouldn't uh
couldn't simply let go now something to
keep in mind here is that this bit of
origin basically intertwines with uh
with eobard thawne fighting off and on
with wally west it's actually kind of
funny because eobard thawne overpowers
wally west in the worst way it's it's
crazy like wally west just does not have
the ability to go against eobard thawne
but this is kind of a stepping stone to
wally west becoming a greater flash
becoming faster than barry allen was
becoming more capable than barry allen
was just because of the fact that eobard
thawne as he exists now has all the same
powers that barry allen had before he
died during crisis universe so it's
really kind of a comparison kind of a
you know where does wally west stand in
comparison to where barry allen was and
it just shows you how much more powerful
barry allen was than uh than wally west
but the fact remains here that the the
next step in eobard thod's plan is to
basically duplicate the powers of the
flash now the funny thing about this is
that uh with regards to eobard thon when
flash initially gained his powers it was
just you know being bathed in some
chemicals and struck by lightning and
that is the formula that eobard thawne
uses in order to give himself the powers
of the flash but i want you to keep this
in the back of your head because as we
progress through this what we'll
actually do is we'll reference jeff
john's flash rebirth and the lengths
that that eobard thon went to to
actually make barry allen the flash to
ensure that eobard thon's history or i
guess his future actually comes into
existence but because of the fact that
the only way to use the cosmic treadmill
to basically transition back and forth
through time uh was to have the power of
the speed force or the power of the
flash that's exactly what eobard thon
did he gave himself the power of barry
allen now jumping into the past itself
what eobard thon does is he describes
this as extremely rigorous and extremely
mind-numbing and almost driving him
insane and it's interesting because of
the fact that whenever people usually
travel back and forth through time
unless you're talking about like time
trapper or something like that it's not
something that dc delves with on the
regular you don't routinely see people
traveling back and forth through time in
dc the way that you see with like marvel
comics with marvel comics people like
cable just jump back and forth through
time as if it's nothing you know they
just kind of do it on a regular basis
you know bishop does it on a regular
basis now because of that marvel has
gotten time travel at least the
principles of how a person time travels
in comics down to a t marvel's problem
is continuity and cable is a retconning
machine he literally just exists to go
back and change things in the past
that's all he does it's it's his his
cable is a weird guy when it comes to
comic books but the fact remains here
that with uh with with eobard thawne
transitioning back into the past his
mind is in an altered state not
necessarily that he is um you know high
on the experience or anything like that
but he's in a very fragile state he's
literally walking a knife's edge between
sanity and insanity now the problem with
this is that when he travels into the
past he travels into the past in the
post-crisis landscape now this begs some
questions this really asks you know
requires us to ask a few questions if
prices on infinite earth was an event
that basically existed to eliminate the
multiverse and reset dc's continuity
then does that mean that eobard thawne
actually did go back to the point when
crisis on infinitives happened but
because crisis happened he effectively
hit a wall he couldn't travel back any
further you know and so it's like safe
points or something like that for those
of you guys who play video games you
know with chrysler infinite earth it
basically said no one can travel before
this event took place so eobard thon set
the calculations right did everything he
was supposed to but basically hit a wall
of continuity and couldn't travel back
to meet barry allen before the events of
christ's son infinite earth because of
the fact that the multiverse in all time
had basically been reset so again i kind
of asked a few questions here and there
and really mark wade doesn't ask us
these questions in the comics it's just
something that i happen to think about
and something that seemed uh seems sort
of interesting but in order to keep
things from getting wildly complicated
we're not going to invoke crisis on
infinitives any further aside from
referencing why it is that barry allen's
dead but what ended up happening here is
eobard thon this is actually a really
funny moment here e bar thon in his
little skirmish with wally west while
he's telling wally his origin while he
basically grabs an object and tries to
throw it and eobard thought he martha
pawn whips around knocks it you know
knocks it away and says don't do that
again and that's a really cool moment i
really really love that's one of the
things i loved about eobard thon's
character there's so much arrogance so
much hubris you know but so much power
and he's just he's just cool man like
i think hillbar thorn is so cool that's
why i'm really hoping he comes back at
the flash tv show because he's one of my
favorite characters but getting back
into the story what ended up happening
here is that eobard thawne walking a
knife's edge began to see him slipping
down the path of madness and the reason
why is because instead of being logical
and reasonable as his intelligence and
as his wealth dictated what ended up
happening is he basically said well the
reason why i'm here in the post-crisis
landscape when you know biryan's already
dead is because fate led me here fate
wants me to be the new flash fate wants
me to take over the role of barry allen
now honestly this is just wishful
thinking i mean that's that's really all
that is it's it's eobardon taking what
he wishes were true and making it true
of course we know wally west is the
flash but what is up happening is that
because eobard thon takes this mission
onto himself and comes to believe that
he's the guy who's supposed to take up
the mantle of barry allen what we end up
finding out here is that he begins
transitioning through the different
histories all the different villains of
barry allen learning everything he can
about them what their strengths are what
their weaknesses are using his
intelligence to benefit him as he
analyzes these individual guys only to
stumble across the most dangerous foe of
barry allen who's revealed to me eobard
thawne himself now this is when his mind
fractures this is when his mind
basically goes sends him tumbling down
the rabbit hole and what ends up
happening here is eobard thawne
basically begins to realize that if he's
destined to be the bad guy if he's
destined to be the most formidable foe
of barry allen then basically he can run
away from his past he can run away from
who he is and he can make himself barry
allen now the ironic thing about this is
that in an effort to keep from becoming
professor zoom becoming you know reverse
flash he makes himself reverse flash
he's literally living out the actions
that lead to him becoming the reverse
flash and that's one of the reasons why
time travel in dc dc comics is a little
more grounded because it basically asks
the question if you see a future event
take place and you travel into the past
to keep that future event from happening
is your time travel and all your
subsequent actions the reason why that
event happened in the first place so
again it's a little more grounded dc is
a little more uh controlled when it
comes to the idea of time travel but the
fact remains here that this really just
kind of uh gives us the origin real
quick just in the sense that that
because of the fact that eobard thon
adopted the mantle of barry allen he
basically went forward as barry allen
which was basically the story the return
of barry allen now eventually um he was
you know he regained his normal self he
realized who he was he basically kind of
accepted his fate that he was destined
to be the villain of barry allen and
that was it that was really you know the
order story of him going forward within
the realm of dc comics in the post
crisis universe landscape now something
else that i want to point out here is
keep in mind this is the main dc comics
this is not the injustice universe like
we said in the the brainiac video like
we said in the atrocitus video the idea
is to basically grab the origins from
these different characters and then see
whether or not you know if they'll match
up with injustice just because of the
fact that injustice routinely does not
really cover origins and justice just
gives us those characters so again i
want you guys to have a reasonable idea
of where these guys are hailing from and
what these guys stories are about
okay so continuing our series on uh
injustice 2 origins which we're kind of
doing until you know the injustice game
comes out uh really or at least until we
finish all the origins for the the newer
characters we might even go back and do
origins for the existing characters i'm
not 100 sure yet but we focus our
attention on firestorm now here's the
deal as far as i've been able to tell
the firestorm that we're gonna see in
injustice 2 is jason rush it's actually
not ronnie raymond now i could be wrong
and if i am it's no big no no huge deal
we'll just go back and do ronnie
raymond's origin too but jason rush is
basically the second iteration of
firestorm now in truth dc had a lot of
time to work out the kinks with the
firestorm character when it was ronnie
raymond and martin stein uh the idea was
though that you know going into like the
lead up to like infinite crisis you know
going into the basic kind of doing the
soft reboot with the infinite crisis
event the idea was to get rid of ronnie
raymond and replace him with somebody
new now traditional fans of firestorm
hated it people who were looking for
something new loved it the standard fare
when it comes to changing up characters
and comic books uh but jason rush is
actually a pretty cool character i
really like the way his uh his whole
power and his thing is done but i want
to talk about something called the
firestorm matrix for a second because
this is something that that really seems
to throw people off the firestorm matrix
is a pretty simple thing it's just a
just a different way of saying the power
of firestorm now the idea is what can
firestorm do what can like jason rush do
so jason rush has the ability to
basically manipulate the atoms of of
objects i mean he has you know his whole
fiery power and all that kind of stuff
but he can manipulate the the i guess
the atomic structure of objects but he's
limited to the atoms in that object so
say for example that jason rush were to
pick up like a brick all right he could
rearrange the the atoms of that brick to
make it anything else but he can't add
atoms to it so he can't like you know
disintegrate a teapot and then add the
atoms from that teapot to that brick it
doesn't work that way he can only just
manipulate the atoms in that brick now
he can manipulate the atoms to form new
molecules that in turn will you know
turn the brick into like a tablecloth
washcloth or something along those lines
you know whatever it is that he wants to
do but he can only work with the atoms
in that brick so i think it's a pretty
straightforward explanation but his
origin is actually kind of cool here now
the reason why is because it initially
picks up with him working at a normal
job but the issue is that he shows up
with a bruised eye with one of his eyes
swollen shut and what we end up finding
out here is that it was really his dad
who did it that his dad was an abusive
guy now of course him returning home is
a pretty daunting task just because of
the fact that he's got to go back to his
dad and tell him that his employer stand
will not let him continue serving people
so long as his eyes damaged effectively
meaning that he's lost his job
temporarily now of course his father's
response is to lash out but the reason
why his father is so angry at the world
is because of the fact that his dad had
an industrial job but following an
accident where he basically lost his
hand his father became an abusive guy
towards his wife who left and then
became abusive towards jason who was the
only person left and so because of that
the you know exchange between the two is
one of anger and one of resentment
largely because of the fact that the
disability checks that his father gets
isn't really enough to keep up with all
the bills that are coming due and so
jason having a job was kind of essential
but it's basically you know dc sitting
down and showing us this kid's coming
from a pretty tormented place now it's
not like the most violently abusive
place ever right but it is still pretty
abusive and so because of that what's
being shown here is jason is a guy who's
basically struggling with the world now
because of the fact that he's
effectively lost his job and because of
the fact that he's good natured at heart
in the sense that he still feels like he
owes it to his father to help him with
the various bills and so on that come do
especially after his mother abandoned
the family the result here is that she
ends up taking a courier job with a
pretty illicit guy named stevie now
stevie's pretty he's a pretty seedy guy
i mean that's really what's going on
here like this dude is shady as hell and
it's one of these things where it's like
here's a package you don't open the
package you don't look at the package
you don't do anything with it you pick
it up you drop it off at a destination
and you leave and that's the extent of
your involvement he's a basic no-frills
courier now the idea here is that should
this first you know mission so to speak
be successful he'll be in turn provided
more work the problem with this is that
on his way to deliver the package
there's a massive explosion and there's
effectively a shootout at the drop-off
point so the idea here is that those who
were selling basically got in a conflict
with those who were buying things just
started getting cleaned up now of course
jason himself was caught in the
crossfire i'm sorry jason himself was
watching individuals who were killed who
were caught in the crossfire and
ultimately he's basically bonded with
the firestorm matrix now the reason why
this happens is because of the fact that
following uh the removal of ronnie
raymond from the dc landscape the
firestorm matrix had basically become
this source of power so it was almost
like some extra dimensional source of
energy or something along those lines
but it basically was going around
looking for a new host and so it
essentially settled itself on uh on
jason rush now of course with him
imbuing the essence of the firestorm
matrix what is up happening here is dc
starts harkening back to the days of
ronnie raymond and the reason why i say
that is because of the fact that ronnie
raymond and martin stein operating
together as firestorm was essential the
reason being because of the fact that
the firestorm power was extreme in the
sense you know being able to transmute
matter being able to you know achieve
all kinds of crazy powers and things
like that it was ideally too much power
for one person to handle and so what the
firestorm matrix would is basically
doing here is it's pairing people up
with the consciousness of jason rush and
one of the first people that it pairs
him up with is just one of the guys who
was involved in the shootout now of
course this is dc kind of giving us the
lay of the land showing us what happens
when jason rush is
operating as firestorm and what happens
with the voice inside his head when the
consciousness from the other person is
taken now of course again we're kind of
shown two sides of the coin here in the
sense that jason's in control of his own
body when he's operating his firestorm
but he can relinquish control if he's
able to figure out how and this other
guy can do it the problem is that jason
doesn't know how his powers work he
doesn't know how the firestorm matrix
functions all he knows is that it's just
there now of course this results in this
guy basically getting his mind back and
uh you know essentially taking off and
so it's simply just jason again and
that's when dc basically shows us the
idea that you really need two people
it's almost like the the yeagers you
know from pacific rim you know you can't
do it with just one guy you gotta have
two people piloting the pilot in the
yeager by the way how amazing is the
name gypsy danger i really really wish i
had thought of that name earlier and i
could use it for like a playstation
handle or like an xbox handle imagine
like a dj called gypsy danger like live
at electric daisy carnival gypsy danger
like it'd be the coolest thing it'd be
it's an amazing edm handle or something
like that but anyway um so what is up
happening here is that jason of course
reports back to stevie and says hey look
man there was a great big huge shootout
there was an incident the package has
been destroyed that kind of thing and of
course we're not really told what the
contents of the package is but what we
are told is that stevie intends to
basically beat the hell out of jason
along with a few of his guys and so
again this really begins to see the you
know the continuation of the story when
jason goes and ends up you know when he
you know confronts stevie now of course
it isn't a skirmish between the two of
them no huge deal but stevie's mind gets
absorbed into jason now this is when we
learn more about how jason views himself
and the reason why is because of the
fact that stevie's not nearly as
unintelligent as he may seem where
stevie's guy starts shooting up the play
start attacking jason we basically see
you know the various powers he has where
he can put up shields that block you
know incoming bullets and and so on and
so forth the full extent of his
abilities in terms of you know what he's
able to do at this particular point in
time but with regards to stevie himself
his interactions with jason in jason's
mind is basically manipulating him
saying hey look man like i've been
sorting through your memories and while
you're obliterating all these guys out
here while you're literally wiping them
from the face of existence with your
insane amount of power what i see in
your memories is an abusive father like
i see a man who has been tormenting you
ever since you were younger i see a man
who you know basically drove your mother
to leave you know i see an inherently
abusive guy he says look man you've got
so many problems let me solve those for
you like you have so many issues let me
be the one who takes over you know and
those problems will get solved now the
other half of this is that stevie's
basically beginning to erode so because
of the fact that they're conflicting
beings conflicting ideas they're not
really working in unison but also
because of the fact that stevie's not
really ideal for harnessing the
firestorm matrix and so the longer that
stevie stays out of the limelight the
longer he's forced inside the mind of
jason rush the more his body begins to
break down on the atomic level in terms
of you know his consciousness more or
less going away now the end result of
this would simply be that if it went on
for you know if it continued going on
eventually you know stevie's
consciousness would just cease to exist
he would basically just be a body with
no mind inside of it so it would just be
a shell of a human being but of course
you know as they continue to kind of go
back and forth and because of the fact
that stevie keeps prodding you know
jason about his father eventually jason
just kind of lets it all out and then
sends stevie's mind back into his body
again the result is that in the process
with jason learning about his ability
abilities he accidentally more or less
destroys the body of stevie and because
of this because his you know his
physical body reflects the changes in
his uh in his mind uh he's eventually
essentially just kind of reduced down
like a puddle of blood and
flesh and nasty stuff but again as this
origin sort of begins to wrap up what
ends up happening here is that when
jason getting back home of course his
father continues to be abusive he more
or less intends to use his powers going
forward as a means to effectively escape
his brutal situation you know living in
detroit with regards to his dad and the
life that he hates so much but again
it's not the most significant origin
ever it's not the biggest origin ever
there was one other origin that we got
and it was in uh 52 of course that was
the event that came after infinite
crisis and was designed to both give us
you know origins for newer superheroes
as well as focus on the small time guys
while the main superheroes had
essentially vanished but that's two
pages and so there's really not much we
can do with a two-page origin it's like
you know this happened that happened
that happened that happened and we're
done you know so there's there's not a
whole lot you can do with that um i mean
it requires a little more
expansion and so on but again from here
it was really just you know jason coming
into contact with the justice league for
the first time you know meeting with uh
with you know jon stewart and going
against martian manhunter and that kind
of thing and so again it was kind of a
cool thing to see but you know his
origin was one of these things that was
that was systematically fleshed out over
the course of some you know 20 issues
and they were constantly adding things
to it but in terms of how jason rush
became firestorm and what he can do this
is pretty much the long and short of him
that's you know what we've seen here is
really all that we need in the sense
that he's a guy that is able to possess
the firestorm matrix he can manipulate
matter on the atomic scale um he can put
off all kinds of fiery abilities
different things like that create
shields to protect himself i mean he's
able to do your standard fare of of
individuals in dc comics that have these
sort of psychokinetic powers in addition
to him being able to manipulate matter
on an atomic scale but
injustice 2 yes
and justice 2
i'm jerusalem i am so excited to be back
on injustice again
i love the injustice comics oh my god
the injustice comics are so good and
it's it's awesome because we get tom
taylor back on the stories again okay
okay so let's let's calm down let's calm
down let's relax man i'm so excited okay
so in injustice
injustice 2 follows the game like it
follows the conclusion of the game it
gives us a little bit of a time a little
bit of time that kind of laughs in
between but not a whole lot i mean it
kind of you know fills in the gaps a
little bit but what it basically tells
us is that again it's the rebuilding
phase right like superman had been
defeated by the forces of batman by the
justice league from a different reality
and it results in a superman being held
confined in a prison with red sun
radiation of course red sun radiation
effectively neutralizing his powers now
the cool thing about this is that batman
goes to visit superman and what really
happens here is it's it's it's amazing
because superman really kind of counters
to batman like the state of where he's
at and what direction he's going in and
this is kind of cool because without
superman there the whole totalitarian
regime is effectively gone but the funny
thing about this is that superman wasn't
wrong right like i mean that was the
whole philosophical argument that we had
in the first injustice you know series
of videos we were basically making the
argument at least i was making the
argument that superman wasn't wrong in a
world of war in a world of conflict in a
world of strife all those kinds of
things superman stripped people's
freedom away yes but replaced it with
order and structure and it really begged
the question if people have freedom and
people use that freedom to destroy
themselves then of what uses freedom of
what uses freedom to a dead man wars are
not won by the people who die wars are
won by the people who live long enough
to win the war and so it's really kind
of a cool concept when it comes to like
the whole injustice scenario and the
whole idea of what direction things go
in now because with superman gone it
sets the stage for the world to return
back to the way it was to a degree but
the world is also broken in a lot of
different ways i mean remember the
governments of the world were forced to
kneel to the you know to superman now
the superman's gone the idea is okay how
do we return ourselves to the way we
were before which means that now people
are looking to the idea of like
corrupted government officials or
looking to the idea of petty squabbles
the world being as chaotic and as you
know screwed up as it was before now the
role of batman in this particular you
know post-injustice year five landscape
is rebuilding how do you rebuild the
world in a way that makes sense now the
funny thing about this is that superman
basically says you can't rebuild the
world on your own because a world ruled
by batman would be crazy like a world
that's that's literally molded in the
image of batman would be nuts because
imagine that you know people would be
terrified to commit crimes i would dare
say it'd be just like superman but by
you know but through a different means
batman would have his own police force
and so on and so forth so yes you know
we're preventing crime from happening
but we're basically still doing the
exact same thing that superman is doing
now of course after this whole
conversation between the two of them
basically comes to an end the cool thing
is that you know superman basically made
the case and somebody's saying hey look
despite all your bravado despite all
your oh i'm batman you know i'm fighting
against crime and all that kind of stuff
he's really just a kid who's trying to
stop two bullets who's trying to stop
the bullets that killed his parents and
this resonates with batman because once
he leaves he starts talking to harley
quinn she's still very much a part of
the batman landscape or i guess you're
really kind of one of batman's allies
and he admits superman is right i can't
rebuild the world on my own i need
people in my corner that can correct me
when i start making decisions that
should go awry and that's really the
huge difference between batman here and
superman and injustice you know in the
whole injustice landscape superman
didn't listen to anybody else he did for
a time but fear governed superman this
is the reason why you know he reacted
the way he did with lois lane died that
he instilled this totalitarian regime
it's the reason he fell to the to the
sinestro corps in the first place you
know as time progressed he became more
ruthless he became more cruel the
justice league stopped being a group
that he confided in and began being a
group that he looked as basically a tool
to use to achieve his own goals now of
course the other half of this is harley
quinn herself and it's kind of funny
because harley quinn remains very much
just this bright funny character in this
story and that's why i love harley in
injustice she's so hilarious uh but in
the middle of basically calling you know
and and talking to her sister about you
know harley's daughter you know talking
about it being her birthday and so on
and so forth we end up having like the
quiver the home base of harley quinn
blown to pieces only to find that she's
met with the arrival of amanda waller
now this is the coolest thing because we
had neither high nor hair to indicate
that amanda waller existed in the
injustice universe we didn't know what
was going on with her and we certainly
had no indication that the suicide squad
was there and so what ends up happening
is where harley quinn makes her escape
she's basically taken out by deadshot
only for her to basically wake up and be
told by amanda waller welcome to the
suicide squad so this is awesome because
now we have the suicide squad in the
injustice universe which really begs the
question you know what kind of scenario
are we going to be seeing here with
regards to the whole suicide squad
concept now from here we pick back up
again with dr fate and this is a
question that i didn't really get a
chance to answer when we were covering
the injustice stories because we didn't
really cover it but this really answers
the question of what happened with black
canary now the whole idea here is for
those of you guys who were you know part
of the whole injustice line of stories
you saw those videos uh when black
canary had been killed by superman and
the moments before she was supposed to
die she was basically rescued by dr
faith as she was transported to another
reality and the reason why was because
dr fate really just kind of took pity on
her you know dr fate said hey look you
know you fought for all the right things
you've lost everything so close to you
you know your son deserves a mother and
your son deserves a father and she and
he basically whisked her away to a
different reality where oliver queen had
survived but black canary had died
somewhere along the line and so what he
did is he basically took two different
versions of characters and paired them
together so we got black canary and we
got oliver queen from two different
universes now this is really kind of a
kind of harkening back to the old school
introduction of black canary because she
was from a different universe she was
from earth 2 i think it was and it's a
really weird history because there was
one point where oliver queen was dating
the mother of black canary and black
canary herself at the same time he was
dating the mom and the daughter which i
mean it's kind of it's kind of cool when
you think about it but nonetheless he
was basically dating them both at the
same time and uh and the funny thing
here is again a little bit of humor they
still have conor you know conor was
brought over from the other universe
from the injustice universe and raised
by this reality's version of oliver
queen alongside the injustice universe
version of black canary but the idea
here is that dr fate showing up is
basically saying hey look uh you guys
need to come back you guys have to
return the war is over superman's lost
it's time to begin jumping into the
rebuilding phase and you guys are going
to be necessary for that so it's really
just a way for tom taylor to bring back
oliver queen and bring back black canary
which makes sense because oliver queen
went out like a hero in the injustice
universe and people absolutely loved him
for it but it's good to see him come
back because what this does is it
basically takes a character that doesn't
know anything about the injustice
universe and it kind of we kind of get
to live through the eyes of oliver queen
so to speak the cool thing about this is
jumping back to harley quinn with her
basically being forced into the suicide
squad you know her argument is you could
not have made a more foolish mistake
like i'm an ally of batman like there
are people who do stupid things and then
there's what you've done here uh which
is probably the worst thing you could
have done now of course this also kind
of hits home to the nature of amanda
waller in the sense that amanda waller
is very arrogant amanda waller is very i
do things my way and either you're along
for the ride or you're done with all
your living but the funny thing about
this is that we basically have the
arrival of batman who ends up taking out
the suicide squad except this is not
batman this is a person dressed up as
batman but this is not batman mostly
because he's just wielding two guns now
as far as i'm aware and injustice so far
we don't know who this guy is at least
as far as i've read as far as you're
concerned we don't know who this guy is
i mean there's all kinds of different
questions that are kind of kind of being
posed here in terms of who this guy is
mostly because of the fact that he
shoots a multitude of people he shoots
amanda waller the whole nine yards kills
them all you know and basically says you
are now my suicide squad now the funny
thing about this is it's also him
basically thinning the herd and this
actually makes sense just because of the
fact that remember people are shanghaied
into the suicide squad and bombs are
planted in their heads to keep them
there it's the reason why they can't
just leave why they don't just rebel
against amanda waller and kill her but
the crazy thing about this is that
whoever this guy is is posing as batman
goes through and thins the herd out i
mean he literally just starts killing
off a whole bunch of the people who were
here because they served no useful
purpose now this is tom taylor kind of
thinning things out right like we
wouldn't expect the clock king we
wouldn't expect you know william talkman
to be a usable member of the suicide
squad what can he do of what purpose
does he serve he's a guy who's obsessed
with clocks in time you know it's
different things like that these guys
are useless in almost every sense of the
word but you know he grabs those who are
useful you know captain boomerang
deadshot captain cold are effectively
brought on board now this inevitably
brings this false batman into direct
confrontation with the real batman and
this is beautifully done because this
false batman immediately overpowers
bruce wayne and it's not even a contest
but notice here notice the the notice
the movements that he has he's fluid
he's trained in martial arts he knows
every single move that bruce wayne's
gonna make and he counters every single
one of them if i didn't know any better
i would say this is like jason todd or
it's somebody who trained bruce wayne so
again it's really kind of a cool
scenario because it begs the question
what's going on here how are things
unfolding who is this guy who's posing
as batman now of course following this
this of course leads into the really the
introduction of lucius fox it leads into
bruce wayne recovering under the care of
barbara gordon but we also get a message
from lex luthor remember in the original
injustice stories lex luthor was a
friend to superman before the events of
lois lane dying at the hands of the
joker but when superman basically became
a bad guy lex luthor secretly worked
against him in support of batman and so
the two of them were basically allies
now the whole revelation of what lex
luthor was about all really kind of came
to a head in year five which resulted in
lex luthor basically being revealed as
having worked against superman which
ultimately led to his death but because
of the fact that lex luthor is no longer
there what he basically ended up doing
is he took all the money that he had all
the resources that he had and willed
them to bruce wayne and so bruce wayne
is all the richer now but again lex
luthor reiterates the exact same thing
that superman said he says look a world
molded in your image would be terrifying
what you need are allies you need allies
with money and you need allies with
ideas now again this is cool because
this really continues this is tom taylor
hitting home at the idea that bruce
wayne's not perfect batman's not the
best good guy ever batman's an anti-hero
if batman's not careful he'll become
superman and that's why this is so cool
because superman tells him that lex
luthor tells him that the world tells
him that you cannot make the world in
your image because you are not perfect
you're not some benign godly being that
knows everything about everything and
will always make the right calls you
make mistakes you do the wrong thing
this is evident in injustice year one i
mean this is evident in injustice year
two it's evident in injustice year three
and four and five batman consistently
had opportunities to take down superman
he consistently had opportunities to
work it out in a different way but he
constantly kept coming back with his own
insurgency you know ultimately it led to
the two of them coming to blows which
led to the you know the whole of the
injustice event in the first place but
the fact remains here that this is again
you know kind of this this idea being
reiterated that bruce wayne cannot make
the world in his own image now of course
this also sees black canary arrive
alongside the alternate reality version
of green arrow this is really really
cool here because we get a little more
information about this alternate version
of oliver queen we didn't really know
much a you know know a whole lot about
him when he was first introduced and we
didn't need to at the time it was just
oh my god you know black canary gets a
good send-off she gets a nice farewell
she gets a happily every after and
that's all we needed because it was just
this one little shining ray of hope and
then the original injustice line of
stories when all we got was just
darkness and death and sadness and so on
and so forth but what we find out is
that this version of oliver queen for
whatever reason lost everything he lost
all his money we don't really know what
it is that happened what we do know is
that he lost virtually everything but
the response to batman is well that may
have been in that universe but in this
universe none of that happened you're
still a billionaire and it's your money
and you know black canary's money
because the two of you are married which
ultimately leads to black canary
proposing to him because of the fact
that in this universe they're not
technically married but again it's
moments like these it's these small
little beautiful moments that tom taylor
kind of introduces into the story that
keeps things fresh that keeps things fun
you know that reminds us that the
injustice universe is not something
devoid of happiness the injustice
universe is not something filled with
darkness and sadness and that there are
beautiful things that come out of this
universe these small great little
moments that take place between these
two characters because when we think of
of oliver queen and black canaries you
know they they really go together like
like peas and carrots i mean they are
two people who are kind of this hallmark
of the superhero community it's really
kind of funny because we end up having
this scenario where of course this alarm
goes off you know we end up picking up
with the warden of the prison that was
created by batman a guy by the name of
turpin which ultimately reveals that the
power to the prison has been taken down
now under normal circumstances this
wouldn't be a huge deal and while it
does have backup generators those backup
generators have been disabled the reason
why that's a problem is because the the
red solar radiation is powered by the
prison if that power goes down there's
nothing to keep superman contained and
so ultimately superman begins to break
out now of course the question has to be
asked here who took down power in the
first place and how did all this get
pulled off now of course where turpin
and these guys begin responding as best
they can while batman and his crew are
in route we end up having this false
batman show up again and the cool thing
is that this false batman basically has
a suicide squad go through and start
taking out all these different people
who were there now the initial
indication is that this false batman is
going after superman basically saying
hey look we have to find superman we
have to get him out that's the
implication that's given to us here
ultimately of course we end up having
oliver queen and we have you know
barbara gordon and black canary show up
and basically kind of you know save the
day but again a funny little bit of
humor that's interjected in here when
deadshot shows up with the intention of
taking out black canary and taking out
barbara gordon they're all basically
saved by harley quinn but remember
harley quinn was basically kind of
rescued you know from the joker rescued
from uh the intention of superman to
kill her by the original oliver queen
who died at the hands of superman and so
with him being here harley's just kind
of thrown back to the idea of oh my god
you're alive it's a beautiful hilarious
moment here because we actually have
this funny scenario where the question
is asked by oliver queen like like
what's the deal like were we friends
here or something like that harley's
like no we weren't just friends we were
lovers
which of course she's just messing with
him but it's hilarious to see the
response it's hilarious to see oliver
queen just kind of freaking out again
getting back into serious things we pick
up with batman confronting superman and
this is absolutely genius and it's one
of the things that i love about this
batman is a superhero who usually thinks
of every possible scenario you know he
thinks of every single situation that
could either benefit or work against him
in the case of superman if he ever were
to get free and never were to get out
into the solar radiation of the yellow
sun that the earth orbits it would
result in him being restored back to
full power and if that were the case
there'd be almost no way for batman to
take him out again or at least that
seems to be the case but again this is
batman basically saying hey look we had
contingencies like you did you really
believe that i wouldn't account for
power going down like the most logical
scenario you really believe i wouldn't
account for that i mean it's the most
expected thing to happen that somewhere
along the line power would fail where
somebody would break in take down the
generators this kind of thing was
planned for and so what bruce wayne had
done is he had contacted the atom and
literally had the atom enter the ear
canal of superman with a shard of green
kryptonite to keep him under control
sheer genius it's a beautiful bit of
thinking because it's this idea the
batman has genuinely thought of a lot of
different scenarios by wish to take
superman down now of course this
continues to beg the question what's
going on with this evil version of
batman what in the world is happening
here well of course when this evil
batman shows up the scenario that's put
forward by harley quinn is look i mean i
have to go because i'm part of the
suicide squad but we were never here for
superman we were here for damien wayne
and this is when we find out that this
was all just a ruse and what this shows
us is that this evil version of batman
is every bit as intelligent as bruce
wayne and so what we end up having is
talia al ghul alongside some unnamed
girl now of course with rescuing damien
wayne what this also does is this keeps
in mind the loyalty of damian wayne
because remember with damian's character
in the original injustice series it was
interesting with him just because of the
fact that for him he was consistently
torn between loyalties i mean he looked
to batman and said look i mean you're
the guy who raised me you're my dad you
taught me everything i knew but he also
allied himself with superman because he
agreed with superman's vision but damien
wayne still had loyalties he still had
loyalties to his friends he still had
loyalties to the justice league and so
while they were all held captive and
while they're all still held captive and
the intention of talia al ghul is to
break damian wayne out of prison his
response is we have to rescue everybody
else they are my allies i remain
honorable i stay true to my allies now
of course this offer is basically turned
down turpin and his guys who show up are
all killed and damian wayne is taken
away but what we end up finding out is
that this woman who came alongside talia
al ghul is a girl by the name of
athanasia the daughter of the bat
presumably the daughter of bruce wayne
let me tell you something right now
right now let me tell you something man
god i get excited during injustice
comics my dog max is excited during
injustice comics god i love injustice
comics okay so here's here's the beauty
of injustice uh really like the first
the first injustice line of stories
years one through five the beauty of
this is that we got some crazy moments
where it was like just attack everything
let's just destroy it all
and it was like these really cool
moments but at the same time we also got
like these these great moments that were
kind of tender and they dealt with the
nature of the characters and so on and
so forth but the cool thing about
injustice 2 is it builds on that but it
also takes this question and this idea
of who is the fake batman now in my
personal opinion i think the fake batman
is red hood i asked you guys that
question in the last video and i was
like would you like who do you think the
fake batman is like most people were
like it's probably jason todd like i
mean i don't know why it wouldn't be is
the fake batman jason todd just like
clickbait the hell out of the title i
have no idea
[Laughter]
but the fact remains here that this is
an insanely great story because this
deals with two different things one it
deals with the daughter of harley quinn
and two it deals with damien wayne
because remember damian wayne was this
character where in a lot of ways with
the injustice line of stories at least
the first in justice line of stories dc
was just relying on our existing
knowledge of damien wayne from just the
mainline new 52 line of stories you know
from dc in order to kind of fill in the
gaps in terms of what his character's
backstory was what his whole history was
what his training regimen had been like
we got little you know bits and pieces
here and there but for the most part it
was you know who damien wayne is from
the new 52 we're just gonna roll a man
and call it a day and it worked because
we got to see some great evolution with
his character was focusing more on the
moment than it was you know later in the
future and we'll talk more about that
once we get to him but the cool thing
about this is that we deal with the
immediate aftermath of the mission to
try to basically grab superman or to
take out batman because remember we have
this fake batman running around and the
idea was that he had essentially created
his own suicide squad you know amanda
waller had her own squad this fake
batman showed up killed her on the spot
killed the unessential members of the
team and then turned around and made the
maybe what was left of the suicide squad
into his own group but the implication
here in this conversation between harley
quinn and floyd lawton the guy that we
know is deadshot this conversation here
basically reveals that batman this this
fake batman is not running on his own
he's not doing his own thing he's
working for someone and that's what
makes this so cool because it's one of
these things where it's like he's
working for someone is the person he's
working for working for someone then
what does that mean does that mean that
the person that he's working for is
ultimately gonna die he's just gonna
become his you know batman's gonna
become his own leader i mean there's a
lot of questions to be asked with this
story going later on down the line well
what ends up happening here is this fake
batman uh basically ends up taking
harley quinn the rest of the suicide
squad over to meet his employer who's
who's basically revealed to be raz al
ghul now here's the coolest thing about
this raz al ghul as he's depicted in the
injustice line of stories is classic raz
al ghul and really the motivations
behind his character the basic you know
the basis behind his existence is
actually something that's kind of been
lost in the storytelling of this
character over the course of years when
it comes to dc comics for the most part
uh whenever waz al ghul shows up people
think of like the classic moments of his
character so like him stealing the
justice league protocols from batman in
the story um you know tower of babel and
then using those protocols against the
justice league they don't usually think
of these moments about what his
character is really about rozal ghoul is
just a crazy eco-terrorist that's all he
is he's just a guy who believes that
humanity's like poisoning the
environment different things like that
and the goal is to basically eliminate
humanity in its entirety and to allow
the natural stage of of evolution which
in razal ghoul's mind is basically
anybody not corrupting the environment
allow them to sort of proliferate and to
keep things in check now again one of
the reasons why dc kind of backseated
this whole thing when it came to like
this part of his life is because it's a
lot more interesting to have raz al ghul
fight the justice league because he's a
bad guy as opposed to him just like
wanting to save the environment but it's
kind of a cool thing because you look at
a guy with so much power and you look at
a guy with so many resources and you're
just kind of like and all he wants to do
is just fight on behalf of the plants
like isn't that what poison ivy is
supposed to be doing or isn't that what
swamp thing is supposed to be doing and
indeed the popularity of those
characters the more they grew in
popularity in the eyes of dc fans the
more it made sense to have them in the
limelight the more it made sense to have
poison ivy out there the more it made
sense to have swamp thing out there to
have them as the ones fighting the fight
on behalf of the environment not only
that remember the whole idea of poison
ivy and and uh and harley quinn having
had a relationship still seems to be
intact and even if they weren't really
in a relationship together they're still
very close friends so again it's one of
those things that tom taylor really
seems to toy on in terms of their
backstory what they mean to each other
and all that kind of good stuff but
ultimately what ends up happening here
is that the questions more or less
raised about the choices of harley quinn
because remember whenever you're
inducted into the suicide squad a bomb
is planted into your head and either you
can do what the suicide squad tells you
to do or you can die and what was all
ghoul is basically saying is we're going
to basically initiate this campaign
whether we use the resources of superman
we're going to basically commit genocide
now this is kind of cool the idea of
harley over the course of injustice
years one through five the first line of
stories going to injustice 2 was
basically character redemption it's very
easy for writers to come along and like
assassinate characters right like it's
very easy with writers to come along and
say yes see you like harley quinn is
incorrigible she cannot be saved it
didn't work that way instead we just got
like all these little tidbits these
little goodies about her character over
the course of the story that she had a
daughter that we didn't know anything
about you know that she basically had to
leave her daughter behind so her
daughter would never get swept up in the
life of harley quinn that despite the
fact that she knew she had a child
ultimately her ties were to the joker
and really one of harley's biggest fears
was that if the joker ever found out she
had a daughter or if the joker realized
that harley quinn was going to leave the
joker for her daughter it might result
in the joker killing her daughter and so
again it created like these really
intertwining personal relationships but
over the course of injustice years one
through five harley quinn went from just
this crazy sadist sidekick of the joker
to becoming a character that was
redeemed a character that we loved and
so it was all about this redemption you
know making her something interesting
making her something more unique her
whole ties with you know green arrow and
so on it was all just a great aspect of
redeeming her and making her something
better and so in this scenario when she
says we're not going to commit genocide
the beauty of this is that she's
approaching it from a reasonable human
being dare i say a sane human being
instead of being crazy and so again it's
kind of cool because raz al ghul
basically says yeah i mean you could
leave if you wanted to we'd have to kill
you and it would suck i mean you
probably don't care because you wouldn't
do anything terrible but your daughter
would really miss you and that's a
dangerous road to walk because remember
harley quinn's daughter is her whole
world she talks to her as often as she
can you know through phone calls i mean
harley's daughter currently lives with
her sister but raz al ghul basically
saying hey i mean you know if if you
died your daughter would be really sad
when brazil ghoul starts spitting out
these little tidbits about the kind of
things that harley's daughter likes to
do we ultimately end up learning that
raz al ghul has captured the daughter of
harley quinn and that's crazy because
now her daughter's in the picture but
not only that it adds this danger to the
story right because now harley's
fighting a war on two fronts and the
first part of her war takes the form of
okay we've got to make sure this crazy
guy razor ghoul doesn't destroy humanity
but the other half is keeping your
daughter safe and if you have to choose
one which one are you gonna choose the
other half of this is that harley quinn
basically says look you could very well
like shoot me if you wanted to you know
or you could shoot my daughter you know
if you if you chose to kill my daughter
what do you think is gonna happen do you
think i'm gonna side with you do you
think you're somehow going to sway my
mind do you think that somehow you're
just gonna be like oh i'm just gonna be
like oh my god he killed my daughter
well now i've got to do what he wants me
to do no no either harley quinn's going
to die trying to stop rouse al ghul or
even worse she's going to successfully
escape which means then she's going to
have time to formulate a plan and woe be
tied you if harley quinn comes after you
with a plan in mind the idea is look you
know what you're trying to do here is
inspire loyalty and that's one of the
cool things when it comes to raza ghul's
character is because he's not usually in
a situation like this usually he's in a
situation where he's just running the
league of shadows it's usually him just
just saying look you do what i tell you
to and they say yes we do it's not
really this idea of like conflicting
opinions he's not really used to someone
standing out and saying no i'm not going
to do what you tell me i don't really
feel like it i think it's kind of a
stupid idea he's used to just absolute
control and so when you suddenly have
someone like harley quinn coming in and
saying no
you know i'm i'm doing my own thing i'm
playing my own game ultimately it throws
a wrench in the works because roz is not
used to that now something else to point
out here is that roz in the the
injustice universe is not really as
cruel as he is in the in the main dc
line of stories because in the main dc
line of stories he probably would have
shot harley quinn and shot her daughter
and then said and i will kill all of you
and i will just kill everybody that you
know and then just get a new group of
people in here or just do it with my own
league of assassins if you really want
to get in the way and so because of the
fact that a lot of villains just being
in the the position of self-preservation
they would probably get in or you know
probably give in they would probably
just say okay fine we'll do what you
tell us to for now you know and that
kind of a thing and that would be the
end of that roz is extending every olive
branch of friendship here he's literally
believing that he's doing the right
thing and that's what's so interesting
because when harley quinn head butts him
and harley quinn takes him out
ultimately poison ivy grabs her and
basically says look you can't do this
you can't go through this entire
position and just start attacking
everybody because despite the fact that
razakul basically used this nonsensical
thing and said oh well you know your
daughter would really miss you he's
right and that's one of the crazy things
about this is because harley quinn is
acting as any mother would but it's also
her just kind of being emotional and
being irrational in truth her daughter
does need her her daughter does need
someone to raise her because what's the
alternative i mean let's say for example
this played out let's say for example
that this resulted in harley quinn just
refusing to listen to poison ivy and
harley quinn just attacking lazar ghoul
and dying in the conflict well that
leaves her daughter without a mother now
either raz al ghul is going to let this
girl go back to the sister of harley
quinn to continue being raised in
whatever environment she was in but most
likely the daughter of harley quinn will
be adopted into the ranks of lazar ghoul
and be trained to become a prodigious
assassin any chance of her having a
reasonable childhood would be gone in
the blink of an eye and so the idea of
harley quinn is to basically say look
okay fine if this is what it takes in
order to make sure that i can get out of
this alive that my daughter and i can
basically leave and we can have some
measure of a life together then that's
what i'll do and that's ultimately what
ends up happening here now it's not just
the the motivational words of poison ivy
that's sway harley quinn it's also
harley quinn's own conscience and that's
the cool thing about this because this
all feeds back remember all of this
started because the joker tricked
superman into thinking that lois lane
was doomsday superman reacted just took
low you know took doomsday into space
only for the the toxin you know the fear
toxin to wear off and for him to realize
he'd just killed his wife and his unborn
child a nuclear bomb in metropolis was
tied to the heartbeat of lois lane when
she died the bomb went off and
metropolis was totally obliterated and
so because of superman's own actions
which he had been tricked into
committing by you know at the hands of
the joker superman not only lost his
wife an unborn child he lost everyone he
ever knew in the city of metropolis his
whole world blinked out of existence in
the fraction of a second and so again
harley quinn had to look at this and say
yeah she had a hand in it she was part
of this she was one of the people that
made this happen and despite her efforts
her road to redemption raza ghoul pits
this against her because we could be
like the the third party inner corner
right like i mean if we were in this
comic most all of us would say no no i
mean yeah you did a terrible thing but
look at what you've done to make up for
it you are instrumental in bringing down
superman's totalitarian regime you've
given back for what you've done and then
some but raz al ghul is like look i need
this woman on my side i need her to my
cause sure you know i'll do whatever it
takes in order to pull this off and says
yeah you cannot make up for what it was
that you initially did but you can try
to make up for it by siding with us and
so again ultimately harley quinn seems
to give in she seems to say okay and
effectively joins raz al ghul now at
this point we switch over to what i
think is really one of the best parts of
the story with injustice 2 with the
first volume uh what we basically had is
we had the return of black canary and
green arrow remember during the first
line of injustice stories essentially
black canary had been killed so to speak
by superman but the idea was that dr
fate basically stepped in and said no
we're going to save your life i have to
do at least one good thing i have to
somehow act i can't just let all this
evil continue on and so he basically
took a black canary saved her life
whisked her away to a different reality
where green arrow hadn't died and his
black canaria died and so what it
allowed dr fake to do was to pair
together a black canary and green arrow
with greeno having his own son conor
hawk and so it was essentially black
canary treating that version of oliver
queen as if he's the oliver queen that
she always knew you know and they were
basically able to to be raised as a
family now of course because of the
events that are going on with superman
escaping and injustice 2 it ultimately
led to the idea of dr fate grabbing
black canary and oliver queen from that
universe alongside their son and
bringing them back over to the injustice
universe but what this does is it brings
in the third party of conor hawk conor's
like this bit of innocence right i mean
he's been been trained by black canary
he's been trained by oliver queen but he
hasn't seen everything that batman's
seen over the course of his life he's
not like damien wayne and the reason why
this is so cool is because of the fact
that in the middle of his conversation
with connor hawk batman has this
flashback to the early days of him
training damien wayne and what ends up
happening here is that when damian is
initially you know given the role of
robin the the question becomes is he
capable of going out on his own is he
capable of going out and being his own
superhero because remember in the batman
landscape regardless of what era we're
talking about whether it's before crisis
on defenders with dick grayson and the
first iteration of jason todd if it's
after crisis on infinite earth with the
second iteration of jason todd going
into like tim drake and damian wayne and
so on and so forth batman always puts
them to task to see whether or not they
can hold it out there on their own and
it's not just a matter of can they do it
because they have the strength to fight
off different villains can damien wayne
be out there on his own if like killer
croc were to show up it's also can he be
out there on his own and do the right
thing and help the people who need to be
helped because that's that's one of the
coolest things about this because what
ends up happening is batman takes damian
wayne to the furthest side to the to the
part of gotham city that's furthest away
from the batcave telling him it takes
three hours to get from this point to
the bat cave without stopping and so if
you can pull that off if you can do that
then you'll be you'll basically prove
that you can get out on your own now the
funny thing about this is that while
this is a time trial it's a moral trial
and that's one of the greatest things
about this because we get these little
tidbits of damian wayne we get these
little itty bitty you know introduction
aspects of his character and it's this
idea that damien was a good guy and
again that's really what we see a lot
going on in like the mainline dc stories
you know whether it's classic dc before
the new 52 dc during the new 52 it's
damien wayne basically redeeming himself
in injustice we didn't really get that
we got it in so far that he realized
that maybe superman wasn't 100 right but
in the end ultimately sided with
superman because he believed that bruce
wayne was not right in any form or
fashion that humanity had to be
controlled and so again it was really
this idea of how did we get to that
point what happened to damian wayne in
the past that there was no chance for
redemption and what this really does is
it basically tells us that he had every
opportunity that he was a good guy he
shows up you know four minutes in and
he's facing off against bad guys who are
trying to mug a woman the woman gives
him five bucks this adorable kid says
look we can't really take money i mean
we can't really take like tips or
anything but ultimately she ends up
giving him five bucks anyway half an
hour in he talks a man off a ledge from
killing himself and shares coffee with
him notice these things about damien
wayne notice the character that's being
portrayed here he's a genuinely good kid
he's doing the best he can he's helping
those who were in need and that's what's
so great about this is because it's like
fast tracking all the redemption that we
had in the mainline dc stories in the
mainline dc stories you got to keep in
mind it took you know better than five
years in order for damian wayne to gain
some measure of redemption for him to
get from his original introduction you
know during son of the bat you know the
whole idea of him being being just a
train killer that had to be harnessed
you know during the son of that story
all the way up to right now in teen
titans rebirth it took years in order to
pull that off what we're getting here i
think is more impactful because it shows
us him doing the small things and
ultimately it's the small things that
really show what characters are capable
of you know there's a guy who's stabbed
damien wayne brings him to the hospital
there's an old woman getting on a bus he
gives you know he carries her groceries
and helps her on and she ends up giving
him a tip a couple of guys try to rob or
try to commit a crime he drops them off
in front of the gotham police station
this trip that was supposed to take
three hours ends up taking 10 hours and
47 minutes and it's not because damian
wayne's lazy it's because he was doing
all the right things he was helping as
many people as he possibly could and in
the face of failure in the face of
realizing that when he got back the
batman would say you failed this test he
did it anyway and that's why damian
wayne is so cool in the injustice line
of stories because it's this idea that
if he sets his mind to task and if he
says i'm going to do the right thing and
i don't care what the consequences are
then he will do that and he will not
worry about the consequences translate
this to the original conflict between
batman and superman it makes sense that
he would take the stance that he did it
makes sense that he would look around
the landscape and say okay who's really
right here you know batman who says
people should have freedom even if it
means that freedom is going to lead to
the destruction of society as a whole or
superman who says we're going to take
that freedom away and we're going to
save society from itself damien wayne
sided with superman believing that he
was absolutely right knowing that he was
absolutely right damien wayne went with
him damian wayne went with his gut said
okay eyes damian wayne believe that
superman is intrinsically 100 right
whether superman really was or not
damian wayne believed that he was right
knew that he was right and sided with
superman because of that this backs up
that decision this basically gives us an
explanation for why it was he did that
and that's why it's so cool because what
we end up finding out is that it took
bruce wayne three days to make it
through the city of gotham at one point
when he went from that point all the way
to to the bat cave it took three days
for him to pull it off because he was
trying to save everybody he could come
across so again that's why the original
indication was that well as a time trial
it's a time test you have to make it
back in three hours when in reality it
was a moral test will he do the right
thing when he doesn't believe anybody's
watching him and that's when batman says
you can go out on your own that was the
test the test was to see will you do the
right thing if you think no one's
watching you what will you do when when
you believe there's no eyes on you and
demi and wayne did every single right
thing and so again it's really this this
great idea because he officially steps
into the mantle of being robin now of
course alfred being alfred the funny
little thing about this is alfred says
look bruce wayne like your dad will tell
you like there are times when you're
going to be out there on your own and
there's going to be nothing you can do
he's going to be watching you every
single time if for no other reason to
just make sure that you stay safe and so
the cool thing about this is that
because of the fact that damien wayne in
the in the eyes of bruce wayne had
basically fallen from grace because
damien wayne you know really kind of the
path really started with him
accidentally killing dick grayson and
then ultimately falling down the path of
joining superman because of the fact
that it all led to damian wayne and
batman being at odds being enemies
batman looks at conor hawk as a chance
to start over he looks like conor hawk
as a chance to do the right thing this
time around and so while we don't really
know what it is he's doing what we do
know is he basically approaches conor
hawk with some kind of a device and says
you can't tell your parents about this
whatever it is that we're doing is gonna
be my little secret it's gonna be our
little secret between the two of us
so we are back with injustice yes we are
it has been a little while since we did
an injustice video god injustice 2 is is
amazing i mean it's one of these stories
where it just raises more questions than
it answers now for those of you guys who
are uh new here to my channel who are
just now joining the injustice videos on
my channel injustice 2 the comic book
series is designed to serve as the basis
behind the entire injustice 2 video game
much like the first injustice comic book
served as a prelude to the first
injustice game this is a prelude to the
second game the idea here though is that
we're still getting a kind of bolstering
of things and at this point with regards
to our story we don't really need to
know everything that's going on behind
the scenes just because of the fact this
is only really going to deal with like
batman supergirl blue beetle jaime reyes
and ted cord and so on and that's really
going to be about it but the idea here
is that again you know if you're if
you're essentially new here in the first
part of injustice 2 following the events
of the first injustice game the defeat
of superman so on and so forth lex
luthor had left a hologram behind
following his death where he spoke
directly with batman and what he
basically said is there are two options
that batman can choose batman can follow
this path where he decides to recreate
the world under his own image which
would be horrifying because it would be
a world that was immersed in fear
essentially because remember batman is
the avatar of fear that's how he
functions that's what he does that's how
he tries to keep criminals in line in
the city of gotham the other half of
this is to reach out for help and ask
other people to assist in basically
rebuilding the world and of course
batman chose to reach out to other
individuals but one of the people that's
chosen here is ted cord now what this
does is it transitions over to ted cord
proper while he's training uh training
jaime reyes and that's one of the cool
things here those are the guys who are
new to all this there were really two
blue beetles before jaime reyes jaime
reyes was a character who was introduced
as part of infinite crisis and you'll
actually find those videos down in the
playlist if you want to get yourself
refreshed on who jaime reyes is and
about blue beetle and you know ted cord
and so on but assuming that you don't
want to do all that
the long and short of it is this the
blue beetle traditionally derives his
powers from a scarab and the scarab was
actually a device or kind of this
technological weapon that was created by
a by an alien race called the reach and
what they ended up doing was basically
using the scarabs as a way to infiltrate
other planets and so they would
basically disperse these scarabs out
into the universe and a scarab would
land on a planet and then the scarab
would just wait until that society
reached the point where they were
technologically advanced and they were
worth conquering and then the scarab
would activate and bond itself to a host
it would tap into the database of the
reach it would basically begin
reprogramming this personal host and
then turn them into an individual that
can effectively help to bring down that
society from within now there was a
scarab that landed on earth and it's got
its own history and so on and so forth
but in terms of the blue beetle roll
that came to a guy by the name of dan
garrett and dan garrett was just like
this archaeologist that stumbled across
the beetle he was a guy that basically
existed before crisis on infinite earth
but eventually dan garrett vacated his
role he essentially retired and ted cord
picked up the mantle of blue beetle the
difference here is that where the beetle
worked for dan garrett and it allowed
danger to tap into its powers and so on
ted cord couldn't do that and so in
truth tad was really more blue beetle by
name only as opposed to actually having
powers now he was still pretty effective
i mean one of the funny things about his
character over the course of dc's
publication history and even writers
would make fun of it with regards to how
his character would talk and so on is he
was like the least respected superhero
ever nobody ever really gave him any
credit but then the whole events of
infinite crisis happen and a villain by
the name of maxwell lord shot him in the
head which set in motion the whole idea
of the superheroes banding together and
wonder woman killing maxwell lord again
all that's in countdown to infinite
crisis and you'll find that down in the
description following the death of ted
cord in the events of infinite really
countdown to infinite crisis a kid named
jaime reyes you know became the next
blue beetle and then you know you had an
event called 52 which i believe it was
52 uh which was basically a year-long
series of comics that dealt with you
know jaime reyes learning to become the
blue beetle and so again it was really
kind of a cool thing but what this does
with regards to injustice 2 is it feeds
into that because it's basically jaime
reyes learning to become the blue beetle
now something to take note of here is
this does not follow perfectly in line
with jaime reyes as he existed in dc
comics in the mainline dc stories and
the reason for that is just not really
explained here we don't really know how
ted cord met jaime reyes all we know is
that they're working together and in
truth this is really just designed to
kind of feed on people's existing
knowledge of jaime reyes and ted cord as
opposed to create something new and so
what this does is it really kind of
leads to the idea that ted cord had
essentially backed off he had walked
away from the idea of being blue beetle
and in turn tammy reyes became the new
blue beetle in in his place now of
course the other half of this deals with
batman and again batman's going around
gathering resources gathering people who
could help in order to basically rebuild
the world and that's kind of the cool
thing here because this financial
incentive the richest people in the
world have all sorts of money that can
be used to rebuild towns to rebuild
streets to help you know organize
society again to basically restore faith
in humanity that the world can go back
to the way it was before now this is
really a little bit of wishful thinking
on behalf of bruce wayne because with
something like injustice taking place
superman the most idolized and revered
superhero among the entire community in
on earth in the dc landscape becoming a
bad guy and trying to take over the
world that forces humanity to cross this
psychological line that they can't come
back from and so because of that i mean
things will never go back to the way
they were before but things can still be
pretty decent they can still be pretty
reasonable and so it's kind of a cool
thing just because of the fact that
there's a bit of an argument that takes
place here between ted cord and batman
of course ted cord making the argument
jami reyes is too young he's too
inexperienced he's not ready to be the
blue beetle superhero yet now again this
is kind of cool because this hits home
at the idea of jason todd and this is
one of the reasons why a lot of people
are saying that this the evil batman the
other batman that exists in injustice 2
is jason todd because the the whole idea
is that when ted cord and batman are
arguing ted cords basically says you of
all people should know the consequences
of sending a kid that's too young into
the battlefield this hits back at jason
todd jason todd of course being one of
the most notable robins the one who was
killed by the joker the one who
eventually came back as red hood a
vigilante that you know basically tried
to take out crime and gotham by becoming
part of it and subverting it from within
it's really kind of a cool story when it
comes to the whole idea of what in the
world is going on with regards to
injustice so it's these small little
goodies these small little tidbits
because remember in injustice 1 they did
the exact same thing and in justice 1
they would drop these little tidbits
drop these little hints and then would
all come together and basically answer
the questions that we've been dying to
get the answers to over the course of
the whole story and so ultimately batman
says look i'm here to see if you are
willing to help to see if you're willing
to pull things together for resources in
order to make the world a better place
of course tedcord's like yeah man i
guess whatever i'm rich but the idea is
that you know following batman's
departure ted cord is met with the
arrival of booster gold now the reason
why this is so important is because
historically speaking in in dc comics
you cannot have ted cord blue beetle
without booster gold
and rightfully so following crisis on
infinite earth in 1985 dc dropped off
the idea of the justice league of
america as we traditionally knew it
which is to say batman superman green
lantern wonder woman flash aquaman and
so on and they replaced it with a team
called justice league international and
then eventually that became justice
league europe and there was like extreme
justice and so on and so forth but the
idea here is that during this landscape
of these varying justice league teams
booster gold and blue beetle basically
became these sort of comedic characters
they had these hilarious moments and
they really provided a lot of comedy in
a story that would have otherwise just
been too draby and too serious and so
because of that a lot of fans began to
fall in love with the characters of blue
beetle and booster gold just because of
how funny they were and so what this
does is basically restore the idea that
not only do they have a long history in
terms of being teammates but they're
extremely close friends and it's really
kind of dc teasing on the idea that they
might even be lovers but the general
idea here is that when it comes to their
characters booster gold and blue beetle
they really maintain each other's trust
more so than anything else and so
booster gold popping up on the scene and
saying hey i'm gonna be there at the end
under normal circumstances would freak a
person out like what do you mean i'm
dying you know but again with regards to
blue beetle he's like well i mean i
guess it's my time it was only a matter
of time before it happened and so again
you know it's really kind of blue beetle
throwing on this suit and booster gold
making fun of him and that's really
about it but it's an extremely touching
moment because what ends up happening is
dark batman's suicide squad breaks in
and then you know cuts off the arm of
blue beetle and whisks him away and so
what this does is it leads into the
whole idea of what's going on behind the
scenes who is it that's really running
the show and what we end up doing is we
actually transition to raz al ghul's
little sanctuary thing now the cool
thing about this is that what we find
out is that in addition to ted cord raz
al ghul is going around and capturing
all these titans of industry people that
deal with coal mining and people would
deal with you know fossil fuels and
natural gas and all those different
things you know all that kind of good
stuff and what we end up finding out is
that in this injustice universe raza
ghoul is very much rooted in his
traditional appearance and what i mean
by that is razal ghul is a character
that has really become bigger than his
original intention which is to say
brazal ghul is just considered to be
this guy that just wants to dominate the
world is how a lot of people look at him
but in truth razal ghul is just an
extreme environmentalist that's really
all it is there should be this balance
between humans and and nature itself but
when humans become a problem then the
idea is to basically just reset humanity
to wipe it all away and start from
square one and mass's ultimate goal is
to basically say look you guys are
literally punishing the earth and so you
guys all lead these different aspects of
society in terms of captains of industry
and so on and so forth and so not only
does he basically destroy all these
buildings that belong to these major
companies killing everybody inside he in
turn has killer croc and a villain named
orca consume all these different guys
one of which is is ted cord and so of
course we have this insanely touching
moment between booster gold and ted cord
when booster gold pops up and says look
i tried to make way for the time stream
because remember booster gold's from the
future he's basically a guy that
traveled into the past as part of a get
rich quick scheme
but the idea is that despite his
nefarious past he ended up becoming a
pretty you know pretty solid guy a
pretty good guy but the idea is you
can't just manipulate time in dc comics
you can't just jump around back and
forth through time there's consequences
and there are authorities that exist i
think it's called the time variance
authority but i'm not going to swear to
that but there are authorities that
exist in order to make sure that you
don't just dance around the time stream
and screw everything up and so the
result is that where booster gold had
tried his best to jump back in time to
stop things to keep blue beetle from
dying to keep tedcore from dying in the
end he was stopped every single time and
so it's basically inevitable that ted
court is going to die in this particular
circumstance and so again what we do
from here is we basically switch over to
our second story which is called when
you wake up and this is basically the
rise of supergirl and it's one of the
coolest things because when it comes to
the origin stories of certain characters
they're almost universal right like
karazhorel was a pre-crisis on infinite
earth's character she appeared as part
of the superman landscape she was
created by otto bender but her origin
story depicted the idea that she was a
character who was effectively older than
superman when he was a baby that she was
the daughter of a man by the name of
zorel by the woman by the name of allura
and the idea was that she was just kind
of living her life and doing whatever it
is that you do on krypton when you're a
kid going to their science academy or
schools or what have you but that
ultimately krypton once it basically
went awry once the corps ruptured and
the planet exploded that she was sent
out as part of astro city as well as
superman who was sent out on his escape
pod but the the issue ended up being
that where superman crash-landed on
earth carol arrived on earth much much
later and so this created this sort of
discrepancy among their ages in the
sense that where kara zorrell was
technically older than superman by the
time she arrived on earth she looked
much much younger and so again it was
one of those interesting situations but
this origin story is rooted into that
but what it also does is it gives us a
lot of their personal life in the sense
that it's basically you know jorel and
zorrell both of whom are brothers are
just kind of having fun and and doing
their thing now they're not carefree
they're not kind of goofy and wild but
jorel is clearly more of like the rule
kind of guy and zorel is really more of
just like hey let's just go and do crazy
stuff but the idea here is that it
really focuses on the notion of
karazoreal knowing where she is
understanding her place but also being
afraid of things that are a little bit
different being afraid of the unknown
and so what is up happening here is of
course you know where she's you know
breaks her arm in the whole experience
and then we pick up six years later we
actually join the fall of krypton and
this is basically the idea of krypton
being totally obliterated by brainiac
once he detonates the core now remember
brainiac has a long history in terms of
krypton in terms of how he's involved
the role that he plays in the
destruction of the planet the idea with
regards to like the new 52 for example
which is to say the post 2011 dc
landscape is that you effectively had
brainiac going around and wiping out
planets in order to stem the flow of
another race that had invaded from a
different universe that origin stories
down in the description it was a little
weird but it was still the idea that
brainiac was the reason why krypton had
been totally destroyed but what
basically ends up happening here in this
ensuing conflict is that zorel is
injured and essentially killed and
ultimately it leads to jor-el and his
sister more or less or i guess you know
sister-in-law allura grabbing cara and
grabbing superman and then putting them
in pods and sending them out of krypton
which of course leads to kara ship being
knocked off course which explains why it
is that she had just been floating out
in space for so long and so where
superman had arrived on earth relatively
quickly i mean there was still a little
bit of time there but where he had
arrived on earth relatively quickly uh
kara zorrell was just kind of stuck in
stasis she was basically just not really
aging she was just kind of floating out
there and eventually shows up 35 years
later so again this feeds into the
traditional origin of supergirl in dc's
comics she was older than superman but
arrived on earth after superman and so
she appeared much younger the difference
is that with this being the injustice
universe instead of being met by the
arrival of superman she's met with the
arrival of black adam and conduct now
this is kind of a cool thing because
remember black adam ended up siding with
the regime he ended up siding with
superman but black adam is a bit of a
wild card because in the original
injustice stories he sided with superman
for no other reason than to keep his
home country of conduct safe and that's
the important thing to remember about
black adam black adam has no allegiances
he doesn't swear allegiance to any one
particular person and under normal
circumstances he kneels to no man he
does whatever it is that he needs to do
in order to keep kondok safe and that's
the nature of his character you can
almost imagine a conversation with him
you know and his answer is i'll do
whatever i have to do if i have to burn
cities to the ground if i have to
destroy the world i'll do whatever it
takes to keep conduct safe the issue
here is that it was black adam weighing
his odds in a conflict with the regime
versus siding with the regime and at the
end of the day he sided with the regime
because as powerful as he is as capable
as he is and even being able to
overpower shazam in some circumstances
black adam would not be able to take on
the combined forces of superman and
wonder woman and the flash and the green
lantern i guess the yellow lantern hal
jordan he wouldn't be able to take them
all on at the same time and keep conduct
safe there would be a loss of life and
conduct itself wouldn't inevitably have
been destroyed we saw that in the first
injustice comic and so the result is
that he sided with the regime and
basically took up arms with them now the
reason why this matters is because
following the events of the first
injustice game black adam retreated back
to conduct and then turned it into
basically a place where people who were
part of the regime and had essentially
disbanded following the defeat of
superman could take up residence and
find solace and so it's really more of
just kind of like a staging ground for
whatever the regime will become later on
down the line and so of course where the
arrival of supergirl is met with the
arrival of you know surrounding
countries all of whom demand to know
what it is that's in uh conduct you know
the idea that this particular general
you know from a place called a balaya i
think is how you pronounce it ultimately
puts his hands on black adam and is made
to pay the ultimate price uh this
basically leads to adam you know again
an indication here that of what black
adam is willing to do in his mind kara
zorrell landed in conduct which means
that she's now a resident of conduct
anybody who steps in and tries to remove
her will pay the ultimate price they'll
be made to understand the error of their
ways and so again it's kind of cool
because what he basically tells his
people is look if she speaks if she
wakes up if she does anything if
anything happens if she indicates she
wants food or whatever the case may be
you come and you tell me immediately and
so of course when black adam goes to
speak with uh with kara's laurel the
idea is she asked what's going on here
and black adam begins to sort of recount
the events that took place during the
injustice game but notice this he does
not do it with an honest eye he does not
tell her honestly what it is that's
going on instead he basically says you
know once upon a time there was this
amazing guy named superman who found the
love of his life and a woman named lois
lane and then a mean evil villain named
the joker took out took away everything
that superman loved and superman
recognized that there are so many
dangerous villains out there that they
have to be kept at bay and so superman
tried to implement an era of peace and
then the mean evil batman tried to stop
him it's very much propaganda but that's
the great thing about injustice because
maybe it's not it all depends on what
side that you're sitting on i mean a man
with a family you know with a wife and
two children may be willing to bend his
knee to a totalitarian society if it
means his family will stay safe whereas
somebody with no family will say why are
you bending your knee to that guy ah you
need to fight everything off but they
don't have a family to worry about at
the same time a man that does have a
family may look around and say i'm not
okay with my family living under a
totalitarian regime things are okay now
but what about five years from now or a
year from now or ten years from now
things could be worse off you know it's
not an absolute thing it's just one of
these circumstances where everybody
views things differently and that's the
whole nature of this is because despite
everything that had happened all these
skirmishes all these conflicts between
batman and superman the arrival of this
justice league from an alternate reality
to help defeat superman from the
injustice universe and his regime there
are still people who swear allegiance to
superman who still say he was right and
he was doing the right thing and so
ultimately the response to supergirl is
then we have to go find superman we have
to go free him we have to get him out
and so again this creates a pretty
dangerous situation because now the
question becomes with regards to batman
if superman was more than he could
handle on his own and if it took five
years for superman to effectively be
defeated then what hope would batman
have against superman and supergirl and
so again it's really kind of crazy plus
this also raises a lot of questions is
this going to be a supergirl with the
kind of power she had before crisis on
infinite earth because supergirl before
crisis on infinite earth was more
powerful than superman in a lot of ways
she was stronger she was faster you know
she was more durable she fought longer
and harder she was the last superhero
standing when it came to fighting the
anti-monitor she was the only one that
can continue to hold her own everybody
else had effectively been defeated
there's a lot of questions to be
answered when it comes to her character
but the fact remains here that this does
uh have black adam basically say kondok
will be your home again hinting to this
idea that individuals who are formerly
part of the regime can now find solace
in kondok as they basically await for
the re-emergence of superman by some
means in order to restore the regime
back to leadership among the planet
earth but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about injustice 2 so far because i
absolutely love it it's like injustice 1
where it's a slow build and then it
starts getting to like all these crazy
events and cliffhangers and so on but
let me know what you guys think and i
will catch you all later
peace